[Music]
you see them every day but you still
don't know what most of them mean their
creators put a lot of efforts into
making sure that these little pictures
can say a lot of things this is how they
made sure that you recognize the brand
and also invited you to buy their
products and sometimes they give it a
meaning without intending to do so just
wait until you see what happened when
coca-cola realized that there was a
secret message hidden in their logo if
you want to watch just one more video
the premium is the platform where you
should go get early access to videos
from the things the taco the trendy the
richest and many other great channels in
one place with ad free browsing click
this link to sign up for free to the
premium and get ready to binge watch
videos from your favorite channels if
this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe to the
things and please give this video a big
thumbs up stay tuned as we show you 15
secret messages in famous logos
Starbucks many of us like to buy a
coffee at Starbucks every day but only a
few of us know what this logo really
means the woman in this picture is
actually a mermaid as you can see on the
first logo from 1971 she had her breasts
exposed and was spreading her two fins
it was inspired by the picture of a
two-tailed siren from the 15th century
leading men off their path and into
temptation and we have to admit that we
are all victim of the mermaids beauty
when we can't keep ourselves from buying
an expensive coffee to make the logo
more family-friendly the breasts of the
mermaid were hidden by her hair from
1987 to 1992 and since 1992 they cropped
the picture so he can't see that she is
spreading her legs now you will think
about this every time you want to go to
Starbucks will you be able to resist the
temptation Apple you are maybe using a
Mac or an iPhone right now and you don't
even know what the Apple means you have
probably heard
it is a tribute to Alan Turing the man
who made it possible for you to use a
modern computer nowadays after seeing
that his work was not recognized
spending time behind bars and being
forced to cure his homosexuality he
decided to end his life he bit into an
apple full of cyanide and passed away in
1954 the bitten Apple is an homage to
him and the colors of the rainbow
represent the LGBT community however
this story is not true robbed an off the
man who drew the logo said that it was
nothing but a wonderful urban legend the
reason for the bite in the fruit is to
make sure that everyone understand that
it is an apple but we'd rather believe
in the myth it is much more interesting
Pinterest we know we shouldn't go on
this website but we do it anyway and
every time we can't help but feel
envious and wish that we could have more
things than we could ever own in a
lifetime the concept is pretty simple
you like it
you pin it and there is something for
everyone from beautiful dresses and DIYs
to funny pictures and artworks but we
have to admit that we are there for the
Disney Princesses pictures the logo
looks simple at first sight it is simply
the name of the website in red what
could be hidden in there if you look
closely at it you will notice that the
letter P is actually shaped like a red
pin this is where the name Pinterest
comes from you pin your interests on the
website like you would pin your favorite
pictures on a board it is so simple but
also really clever at the same time
Toyota you've seen letters shaped like
things but now is time to see things
shaped like letters when you first look
at this logo you might see nothing else
than a random symbol it doesn't look
like letters from any language you know
unless these cars are spaceships or
extraterrestrials but actually you can
see the whole name of the company Toyota
in the logo can you see it if you pay
attention to only some of the circles
you will see all the letters you need to
spell the word will show you use the
circle in the middle and on top to spell
the letter T and use the biggest circle
to spell the letter
oh then use a part of the circle in the
middle and the circle on top for the Y
and a part of the circle in the middle
for the a what has been seen cannot be
unseen
adidas this athletic brand is known for
those three lines it doesn't matter if
you buy shoes pants a shirt or a bag you
will probably see them on your outfit
this is how you could easily recognize
that you are wearing something from
adidas but these three lines are now so
popular that they have been associated
with any type of athletic clothes the
logo changed over the years but the most
recent versions kept the three lines the
trefoil logo was created in 1972 to
represent that the brand was more
diverse as they expanded their business
then another logo in the shape of
mountains was used for sporting goods
representing the challenges that
athletes have to face in 2005 adidas
simplified their logo to maintain
flexibility for the future but no matter
what we can always see the three lines
this brand is best known for the three
logos are still used nowadays on
different products beats when you've got
a go for a run don't forget to bring
your beats by dr. dre the brand's goal
is to bring energy emotion and
excitement to all the music lovers with
premium sound entertainment it is just
like the red color of the logo which
represents energy excitement and passion
and as most of us love music we all need
a pair of headphones actually even the
logo loves music so much that it is
wearing Beats headphones this is not
only the letter B for Beats they would
have used a capital letter instead if
that was their only intention but there
is actually a secret message in this
logo just add a smiley face to it and
you'll notice that you are seeing the
side of the head of a character wearing
headphones that is a great example of
how a logo can be really simple but also
so meaningful
Wikipedia if we had been honest during
our graduation speech we would have
thanked wikipedia the free encyclopedia
for our degree we can find everything
about anything on this website including
what its logo means you have probably
seen this globe made of symbols and
jigsaw pieces during research for your
paper but what does it mean
once again Wikipedia has the answer each
letter or character represents the
multilingualism of the website most of
them represent the first letter of the
word Wikipedia and the Latin letter W
when we bring all these cultures
together this is how we can acquire even
more knowledge the logo was first
simplified in 2003 but this is why we
could see mistakes in different
languages
it was later corrected in 2010 but why
is the globe still incomplete on top it
represents the articles and the
languages yet to be added and as there
are always new things to invent and
discover this globe will never be
complete and that's the beauty of
learning Nintendo GameCube and as soon
as we opened this box we discovered a
whole new world in which we have the
chance to become someone else and live a
great adventure without any risks our
favourite games were Super Mario
Sunshine and Zelda as we spent many
hours in front of the television instead
of doing our homework but no matter how
much time we spent there most of us
didn't even pay attention to this logo
that we saw every day it is really
simple but it is perfect to represent
the name of this console the logo is in
the shape of the letter G and the
negative space represents the letter C
for Gamecube then we can see a cube in
the middle of the logo to represent the
videogame console itself
well played Nintendo well played even
the creator's had fun designing this
go Roxy to be one of the cool girls you
had to wear Roxy this brand has been
trending since the 90s and we think that
the logo had a really cool look to we
were proud to wear these clothes not
only because they looked good on us but
also because we know that our friends
would notice the logo but do you know
that it is actually the women's version
of the famous Quicksilver brand the
pioneer of extreme sports accessories
when you see these two logos together
you'll understand that they have a lot
of things in common the roxy logo is
actually to Quicksilver logos put
together in the shape of a heart it also
looks like two hands put together as a
symbol of love but we are talking about
the love of sports of course does that
mean that girls have more fun and are
more lovable we'll let you decide
Formula One there are millions of people
watching one of the most popular sports
events on the globe and many of them
didn't see what was right in front of
them this logo was moving so fast you
didn't have the time to see it and it
was already gone but let's ask it to
stop for a moment and see what it looks
like
this logo was designed in the early
2000s once again what you have to look
at is not only the shapes but also the
negative space between them you can
clearly see the letter F in black and
the shape in red representing the speed
the excitement and the energy but the
negative space in the logo also creates
the number one Formula One or f1 is all
about who is the fastest but it takes a
little time for us to understand what
the logo actually means Lacoste you
could be wearing one of these alligators
right now and not even understand why it
is there but no matter what you know
that the brand of a shirt is Lacoste as
soon as you see this animal on
but what does it have to do with clothes
actually it originated with an alligator
skin the suitcase Rene Lacoste the
brand's founder and tennis player saw it
in a stores window
the French Davis Cup team captain
promised he would buy it if he won an
upcoming match Rene tried his best but
unfortunately lost but because of this
funny bet the press gave him the
nickname the crocodile in 1933 he put
the logo on the tennis shirt and the
rest is history so just because you lose
a match doesn't mean you lose everything
this is how he created a brand that is
still really successful nowadays NBC a
picture says a thousand words so imagine
all the things a TV show could say you
have probably noticed that the logo is a
peacock but there is a reason why they
chose this animal this bird uses its
beautiful tail to get the attention of
those around him but the channel was
mostly interested in its color they used
all the colors of the rainbow on its
tail to make people buy color
televisions this new invention was
expensive but NBC wanted to convince the
viewers that it was worth it and show
them that they were missing out if they
saw the bird in black and white but
surprisingly the colourful bird also
caused a lot of controversy people
accused NBC of changing their logo to
gay colors when the Supreme Court
decided to bring nationwide marriage
equality but this is the logo they had
been using since the 1980s
anyway they couldn't care less about
what people think and the logo stayed
the same no matter if it represents the
LGBT community or not
Hyundai can you guess what this logo
means at first sight you might think
that it is simply the letter H for Honda
you are probably not wrong but they
needed something more to differentiate
it from Honda as you have seen
previously logo designers like to make
things a little bit more complicated and
create designs that only they and
this is why there is a secret message
behind it the logo is too simple for
anyone to see anything in it so for this
one we'll have to tell you what it is
because it is almost impossible to guess
it represents two people shaking hands
the company representative and the
satisfied customer so every time you buy
a new Hyundai car the company makes a
deal with you to show that they are
going to do their best to make sure that
you like their product they could have
made it clearer if they really wanted us
to know that Pepsi did you know that
simply changing their logo cost Pepsi 1
million dollars it is crazy to think
that this little picture costs so much
but the company believes that it
actually means a lot no this is not a
fat man trying to grab a Pepsi can in a
really long PDF document the designers
explained that it had something to do
with the golden ration that has been
used for centuries because of its
aesthetically pleasing proportions it is
also linked to the Sun radiation the
gravitational field and the energy
fields in balance they even mentioned
the Parthenon the Mona Lisa and decart
then they use the scientific method to
find the right colors which we thought
simply represented the colours of the
United States don't worry if you don't
understand there is probably no one
other than the creators who understand
it but if it is scientific it must be
true right we are not sure about that
coca-cola Pepsi spent 1 million dollars
designing the best logo in the world
only to give the circle a little
different shape coca-cola also has a
secret message in their logo but they
didn't even know about it until someone
told them the logo has changed over the
years from extra swirls to the logo we
all know today but some people saw that
with the red and white colors the brand
actually created a Danish flag between
the letters O and L it is a tradition in
this country to greet new visitors with
a Danish flag but there weren't enough
for everyone so they did
I did to give some flags to tourists in
the airport everyone was happy to pick
up a flag from the coca-cola logo it is
true that you can open happiness with
this drink do you think there are really
many secret messages and famous logos or
people are making up these stories
sometimes don't be shy to tell us what
you think in the comments down below and
that's it for 15 secret messages in
famous logos if you missed part one
don't forget to watch 15 hidden messages
in logos you never noticed thanks for
watching
[Music]